se encuentran ya reunidos aquí en
Palacio Nacional de la Ciudad de México
Andrés Manuel López Obrador Joe biden y
Justin trude para la Cumbre de líderes
de América del Norte el primero en
llegar a Palacio Nacional fue el Premier
canadiense Justin trudea y su esposa
Sophie Quienes fueron recibidos por
López Obrador y su esposa Beatriz
Gutiérrez Müller minutos después antes
del mediodía llegó Joe biden y su esposa
Jill ya una vez juntos los tres
mandatarios y sus esposas Se tomaron la
fotografía oficial y dieron paso a un
almuerzo privado de trabajo previo a la
mesa ya formal de negociaciones en esta
Cumbre trilateral sin embargo la casa
blanca de manera previa difundió un
comunicado con Los acuerdos que se
discuten en esta reunión de los tres
dirigentes entre ellos destaca en
materia de migración
la intención de que la migración sea
ordenada legal y humana para tal efecto
se acordó crear una plataforma
dentro del sitio web de la declaración
de los ángeles para brindar información
a los migrantes encaminada a un acceso
más rápido a las vías legales también en
materia económica se acordó la
realización del primer foro trilateral
en materia de semiconductores con la
participación de altos representantes de
esta industria en términos de energías
limpias se comprometieron de acuerdo con
este documento difundido por la Casa
Blanca a reducir en 15% las emisiones de
metano de aquí a 2030 así como a crear
un plan de hidrógeno limpio en materia
de seguridad se acordó
eficientar coordinar más las acciones y
las estrategias para combatir el tráfico
ilícito de drogas con especial énfasis
en el fentanilo y el tráfico de armas
Estos son Pues los temas que se discuten
en esta en esta cumbre trilateral de
líderes de América del Norte al término
de la cual habrá un mensaje conjunto a
los medios